they took a virus
and they enhanced it for human
infectivity for whatever garbage reason
they came up with
that couldn't possibly be a good idea
right
it's nothing that could be true that
would have made that a good gamble but
they did it and it got out and it made
lots of people sick and killed lots and
lots of people and i believe the full
toll of that virus is far from
understood
but then
we got it
we've got this brand new vaccine it's
based on an entirely new technology and
this cartoon that describes how it works
says exactly why it's going to make you
safe and you're going to get to go back
to life
i looked at that heather and i look at
the description of this i agree it is a
technologically marvelous new
mechanism for
informing the immune system
it's so far from ready to inject into a
human being
or a billion
well that's just the thing i wouldn't
inject it into one human being
given how many unknowns as you say the
um
the degree to which they lost sight that
they did not recognize the complexity or
didn't care oh man of what they were the
intervention they were proposing and how
radically different this was from
anything that they had done successfully
before
right
that was just
a shocker and then
the idea that they wanted to vaccinate
everybody was like
first we vaccinate the world
could you come up with a worse concept
in biology than that
let's take a novel vaccine that that
affects the most complex system in the
known universe which is the human body
in ways we don't understand and give it
to try to give it to everybody
let's put it this way
i mean a you knew they were insane
when
they started with the idea that they
were going to vaccinate all the front
line workers
yeah
but
how about a half
how about we just
start with half
right you just you don't want to take
all of anything and gamble it on this
experiment
right this is this is
these are these are
people so remote from the level of
complexity they are intervening with
um that they just they couldn't
i'm struggling to find words to explain
how irresponsible this was even if there
was no evidence in the trial so there
was anything to worry about right right
this level of novelty
with all of humanity i'm sorry that is
just
it's crazy it's unimaginably dangerous
we're kind of in an interesting zone
here that i can't think of any
other comparable time that i've
experienced and probably
nobody has experienced in this lifetime
which is
if if you're correct and i would say in
this case if i'm correct that
the cost benefit um was extremely bad it
was outrageously risky
then in the long run i think more time
is going to reveal this and and you know
consequences from intervention
intervening the immune system might not
be known for two decades oh yeah three
decades like
so it's an interesting position to be in
though because
it's almost like
if you want to put your
theory to the test this is a great time
to do it because how many times could
you say with confidence
i think there was a a a
error
a historic error has been made here
that we have not seen the full
consequences
thereof that doesn't happen very much so
it's kind of it's in a weird in an
intellectual sense it's kind of an
interesting opportunity like i happen to
think intervening in complex systems
is probably not a good idea that's true
economically biologically politically
you know culturally
and in this case because it was such a
spectacular intervention like
unprecedented intervention my guess
would be we're going to have an
unprecedented
disaster unfold because of it over the
next few decades
yeah
and i'm open to being wrong it'll be
interesting to see if that plays out
that's true
it does not have to be the case that a
disaster is revealed in order for it to
have been unconscionable
sure sure it could have been russian
roulette and
well there's two claims the one claim is
it was a like a immoral decision and
foolish and the other claim is like a
causal claim that the output is actually
going to be
very bad well i think we already i mean
it's interesting to me that you're
cautious about saying i think we already
see
you know especially with the
mrna uh transfection agents
we already see
an impact on all cause mortality that
causes the return to be negative and
that's only a couple that's a year and a
half out from the beginning well so so
the reason i'm being cautious is because
the uh if you're if you're trying to
look at the scope of possible disaster
yep to have a a increase all-cause
mortality bump we'll make the history
books but it's not like it's not like oh
my gosh this is black plague yep
this goes all the way to
genuinely unprecedented disaster for
humanity i'm not saying that's what's
going to happen i don't know but that's
exactly on the table it's all on the
table it's all on the table but i just
want to point out
if they had gambled recklessly yeah
um
and gotten lucky
that would not be a vindication
of their
uh mechanism of decision-making yeah
right
and i mean you know in fact we're stuck
in this position with respect to covet
itself
right we are now battling we had won the
battle over lab leak and now there's
this full court press to reverse the
story and say oh actually it really did
come from the the seafood market right
it's nonsense evidentiary the the
evidence is not there to suggest a
reversal of this conclusion at all but
what people don't realize is that we are
having a proxy battle over whether the
right thing to do
is to stop gain of function research or
quadruple it
yeah right because if it did come out of
the wet market
then the laboratory across the river
um
wasn't fast enough it didn't have enough
money it should have studied harder
because maybe we could have prevented it
right and if it did come out of the
laboratory then the point is well the
wet market wasn't the concern
it was the goddamn laboratory you did
this it's a self-inflicted wound it's
literally the same process of keynesian
reasoning and economics the idea that we
need the government needs to intervene
to to stimulate the economy and then
when the stimulation doesn't work they
say well we didn't stimulate enough in
fact thank goodness we stimulated it
because it would have been worse if we
didn't stimulate so next time we need a
quadruple dose to really get the economy
going it's the same
same reasoning it's pfizer logic before
pfizer
[Music]